[موسيقى]
اكبر تحدي لهذا المجلس هو استرداد ثقه
الشعب في العمل البرلماني لانه لا يخفى
على عليكم وان اعمال البرلمان الفارط نظرا
للاحداث التي مرت به جعل العمل البرلماني
يعني
يكون محل صوره سلبيه لدى المواطن التونسي
وبالتالي لا تحدي هامور ارجاع يعني
المصداقيه للعمل البرلماني
ونعتقد اننا يعني الان سائرون في الطريق
الصحيح وبالتالي اهم انجاز هو انه بعد
[موسيقى]
صلاحيه التشريعيه تحولت الى البرلمان منذ
يوم 13 مارس
ومنذ يوم 13 مارس لم يصدر اي مرسوم عن
رئيس الجمهوريه بل
انتظرنا طوال هذه المده
وحاله السيد رئيس الجمهوريه مشاريع
القوانين على المجلس ونحن الان على تم
الاستعداد
لدراستها وحالتها على الجلسه العامه
للتصديق عليها
[موسيقى]